Drake is pouring out his heart in a
not-so-subtle Instagram post just days
after he and Rihanna reportedly called
it quits the rapper captioned this moody
black-and-white pic to mix up in drama
to free my mind but I'm praying for you
even in your darkest times after teasing
fans with their on again off again
relationship for years the two
superstars have reportedly split after
one month of being official one source
told enews they are seeing other people
another insider tells Us Weekly Rihanna
doesn't want to be held down but
according to people Drake and RiRi never
actually broke up because their
relationship has always been open
besides Rihanna
appears to be just fine on her own she
was spotted on Monday night headed to a
nightclub solo in New York City and eye
witness tells et Reed partied alone and
stayed out until 4:00 in the morning
last week the singer also through some
serious shade at her ex's with this
pointed message none of my exes are
married or in happy relationships so
it's safe to say that I wasn't the
problem
well Rihanna and Drake might have their
first run-in at this year's American
Music Awards they are the most and
second most nominated artists
respectively